what's a tesseract Oh  do you really want to know okay string  [Music]  okay so imagine the Aunt here wants to  get to our other hand we use the usual  four dimensions three spatial ones  length width and height in the fourth  dimension time the ants quickest option  is to walk across the string right right  but it turns out a straight line is not  the shortest distance between two points  not if you use the fifth dimension fifth  dimension dimension outside of the rules  most people know time and space see they  ain't arrives in my other hand  instantaneously so you fold space kinda  full time  well we're like wrinkle time  [Music]